matthieu delormeau il appelle à new york
avec enora oui bien sûr qu'on passe au
coup de coeur et aux coups de gueule y
paraît j'ai plein de dossiers sur vous
il paraît que vous aviez vos petites
habitudes pour le petit déj 1 voilà il
paraît que vous avez fait beaucoup de
ballades et nora c'était plutôt une part
et expos et des couvertures culturel et
vous booster sport et balade c'est ce
qu'on m'a dit je sais toi un gars comme
mathieu a volé la carte de sport d'un
ami pour aller dans un club de sport
américain c'est vrai tous les lots
élevés du sport du coup il a faim toutes
les deux heures saucisses aux faux plat
c'est ce qu'on m'a dit on va tous nous
voilà bien ça mais voilà et il paraît on
m'a dit on m'a dit vous vous avez dû des
soucis gastriques à new york c'est ce
qu'on m'a dit mais qui a balancé il
n'était pas avec nous
il
et notre vidéo il paraît et avec ça dit
soit vous êtes restés vissés aux
toilettes sont messi mais c'est non mary
virage et tous les non mais tu dois pas
parce que vous avez refait la peinture
et des travaux y avait des travaux
voilà alors vous vous êtes un fil ou
parce que vous êtes au courant de tout
et toi tu es une grosse balance je te
juillet mais je te jure comme j'ai pu le
savoir comment il a pu savoir l'espace
et c'est pas mais crois moi tu me vous
raconte un truc pas réglé mais tu vois
mathieu tu nous lundi en loge
attendez j'ai d'autres dossiers sur tout
ça ça va vous montrer les photos
maintenant il paraît qu à mathieu si on
regarde tout le temps dans la glace et
dean face à des miroirs
il se prend toutes les 43 secondes en
photo c'est l'horreur c'est lé fils de
renoncer parce que gentil - comme chez
garçon éduqué je prenais toujours la
place au resto avec enoh qui est donc
face au mur et souvent à la glace pour
laisser à hainaut le champ s'adresse
tant il ya une signature il ya eu je
vous le dis il ya une phrase
exceptionnelle de matthieu delormeau à
new york
kadi moment rester comme ça et effet
battu voix il aura marché ici dans la
rue dans l'anonymat c'est quand même
agréable
non je suis sûr que tu l'as dit est ce
que je dis des bêtises apparaît et paris
vous émerveiller de tous a notamment
vous avez lu lieux de tournage de quand
harry rencontre sally au sjao c'est
génial partout vous voyez quelque chose
vous êtes vous émerveiller de tout fait
vrai ça c'est vrai ça c est pareil au
shopping vous avez fait un essayage de
blousons pendant 30 minutes
finalement les ch'tis à las vegas et
déjà
rappelons qu il paraît qu'il hésitait
entre l'ol et le xl alors aimerais qu
avait aucune différence
un millimètre sur la manche mais il
arrêtait pas il paraît qu'il est resté
une demi heure
il paraît que vous êtes très flipper en
avion paraît que vous possédez petits
cris dans le grand soin les dégâts à
deux ou quoi ou pas et n'aura non c'est
beaucoup c'est plus fort les cris fait
le cri non mais c'est quand il ya des
moments où on sert ici on est dans
l'avion et enfin il faut y compris bah
quoi banon je sais plus en jeunes justin
c'est ça oui et je sers très fort la
personne à côté
voilà justement et mignot et là il nous
paraît que vous avez été dans un cabaret
un peu un homme un peu bizarre mais bon
c'est renée a une aura dans un cabaret
qui présentent des performances
artistiques avec des drag queens et des
trans un donc voilà et il pas là donc
voilà donc ça c'est vous mais paraît que
les protagonistes et en culotte en cuir
et se déhancher sur de la musique façon
depeche mode et voilà on va dire ça et
paré qui est qu'est ce qu'il faisait il
paraît qu'ils aient une performance
inspirée artistique est ce que vous
pouvez la raconter à nos téléspectateurs
mois pour de vrai oui bah oui mais moi
j'étais choqué dans ce cas des droits
c'est que moi j'étais choquée et
moraliser génial c'est liberté c'est
tellement arte ces machins moi j'avais
jamais vu ça c'est un club en fait où
toute la liberté est et sebha est
représentée dans ce club alors qu'à new
york tout est interdite donc on a droit
de fumer en a qui fument des joints à
qui la même chose bref
ah ça non mais j'ai pas nous nous
faisait part extrêmement ont fait ça et
moi j'étais évidemment non mais qu'est
ce qui faisait quoi la performance et à
ne pas raconter ça si vous pouvez
c'était un petit cabaret reste où les
eaux ont des choses dont on dit par
exemple premier show c'est une femme qui
arrivait en fait on découvre que ça à 30
en europe il déshabille totalement il a
des seins énormes et un sexe idem et
ils dansent un peu comme ça pour
représenter un peu la liberté au
mouvement ça passe et ensuite de ça on
your turn over au bout et ensuite
j'avais jamais vu ça de ma vie un bail
et ensuite de ça il se retourne
oui et ce sort du derrière un van gogh
pour appeler à moi à merde y avait ça
aussi il fait bon y ait un truc mais
grand comme ça et aussi à mondaine aussi
une bouteille de bière
non mais j'ai jamais vu ça c'était une
résistance et je n'ai pas cohérent
attention l'abus d'alcool est dangereux
pour la santé à consommer avec
modération et des moments où c'est très
serré très célèbre là bas il ya un show
avec des petits nature qui n'est pas un
frigo mais non il ya des petits nains
qui se baladent pareil des choses qui
derrière
oui c'est énorme et c'est tu peux
m'expliquer en quoi du petit non non tu
peux te donner moi j'étais assez choqué
et nos trouvé ça génial estime cela de
rêve de liberté chez vos vacances à new
york alors tout ça c'est très sympa ces
vacances
moi ce que j'aimerais juste savoir
mathieu delormeau vous m'aviez première
cadeaux ouais alors et il est où ce
cadeau j'ai passé une matinée entière
ouais parce que je vous connais je sais
que vous s'il faut des choses qui vous
amuse un peu c'est que vous êtes un
garçon simple moi je n'ai jamais un
cadeau made you accouche un gros cadeau
vraiment
non il a vraiment vraiment ramener un
cadeau de new york
c'est pas le nain jaune et vert
c'est énorme de petit nom mais il
m'avait il m'a amené vraiment un cadeau
qui va et isa mais là et quand même mon
chéri et wave ou rien et nous le faisons
pour tous pour l instant a regardé venez
voir non mais c'est réglé m'a ramené
plein de trucs vers les chinois
regardent et un joueur de basket gleam
ressemble oui voilà ça c'est quoi sa
femme à ça je sais que ça va c'est bon
c'est bon allez allez votre passé mon
jeu le jeu ça juste un truc est ce que
tu peux - chez toi parce que je pense
pas que tu aies bourg ailleurs est ce
que tu peux vous pouvez chez vous vous
mettez sur le bureau oui vous pourrez
une petite photo et comme vous avez
encore merci merci oui mais plein de
produits de new york regarder du oui lui
c'est du couscous offert des pancakes et
des produits merci d avoir su matthieu
delormeau
tu sais les mecs il a oublié la note
mais attendez il a acheté sa danse est
un truand est des mecs
lci est gourmande foot merci mon chéri 5
cité du rock soul 75010 paris
épicerie anglaise mais non 75010 non
séparé est un piège à la production
parce que moi non moi j'ai vraiment tout
acheter madonna nom de la vérité dit la
vérité en face il ya des prix et les
pieds dessus
il est la vérité je dis toujours la
vérité alors à l'orge il est vrai mérite
et ça ça vient vraiment de new york ça
et ça avec tout mon coeur le reste
merci quand même que non